the prophet was persecuted for flipping
12 years
his companions were killed you're
telling me if i come to your house you
will kill me
and the prophet he got kicked out of his
house he got killed
and after so many years in quran chapter
22 verse 39
that's when allah said the permission to
fight and defend yourself has been given
and you know you've been nonsense so be
a man and say you know what i've been
chatting rubbish then i won't debate you
show some respect show some respect have
you read this for people have you read
this there are oh there's a hundred
hundred verses in this book violence and
murder against
is the reason we are in such a mess
that's a reality no we're in this mess
because people take
islam they are terrorists and they abuse
the nature of islam and you know the
wording of islam you know
they perpetrate evil and it is
completely wrong when the sacred maps
have passed slay the non-muslims
wherever you find them and take them
captive and proceed
and prepare for them in ambush
now guys as you can hear from there he
sounds very confident
it's like he knows what he's talking
about he's he says there's hundred
verses he seems like he knows it off by
heart
you can see his confidence like it's
quite impressive you know
now what we're going to do is very
simple i've been trying to track down
tommy robinson for a very long time
on twitter been on his case the
pressures got to him and he is
kind of falling on my lap uh in a no
homo way
so i decided to call him so i was given
a number
i found out his address i found out what
kai drives everything
just to have a debate with him by the
way yeah so what we're going to do is
just this a clip
now me trying to call him on one number
and the number doesn't go through
then on twitter he says that i'm not
important he doesn't care about me but
for some reason he follows me
tweets about me 24 7 because the
pressure got to him
but he finally gives me a number and i
call him let's see this confident man
who
acts like he knows everything you know
that he is very sure
that we muslims we kill because we kill
people just because they're not muslims
let's see how confident he sounds when
he's on the phone let's hear for herself
[Music]
the mobile number you called is
currently unavailable
please try again later okay guys
i'm just having a conversation with
tommy and he's agreed to uh
he's agreed to a discussion so i'm going
to call him now
just turn the car around okay guys i'm
going to call him now here
hello tommy something
i'm good you you seem very tired
what's up i said you seem very tired
yeah good not bad man so finally we can
talk you know
i've been trying to call you on one
number but i think maybe you blocked it
you told me what i had your number i was
trying to call you but
the line got blocked oh you just got
three now dinner
no no not this number there's another
number that ends with three two one
somebody gave it to me what's her number
anyways it doesn't matter we're talking
now okay um
all right this is this is my agreement
here okay i've got
your house address yeah and i'm not by
the way i'm not planning on coming there
and it's something to do with your
family i've got no problem with your
family
i'm not gonna come to your family your
kids i've got principals
i've tell me two things let me finish
let me finish here
you have been going and spreading lies
about my religion
you chat nonsense so i want a debate
where me and you
we're gonna go over your friend's book
and your claims that we
muslims are supposed to kill the
disbelievers that that's by general we
want to kill everybody this is the claim
that you're making so stand
up to it meet me and let's go over the
quran
let's go for the hadith let's go over
the islamic literature and the history
and let's see if your claims are true
well yeah for one condition
okay go on that way box for charity i'm
saying no listen listen the boxing look
look
you know he's such a character listen
listen listen tommy told me go show me
your position
tommy you're being pathetic should i
tell you why listen mate boxing is not a
problem that's the least of my worries
me and you having a boxing match
is happy days for me do you get it
because even if you go down you're gonna
go down like a man
if i go down i'm going to go down that
command that's not at least
my worries look look look stop running
away stop running away
you know very well tommy tommy
you know you're in big trouble stop
chatting nonsense look i know where you
live
i know your car i know you're telling me
listen to me listen
i know what you're doing i know i'll
give you the address now no i don't want
to do it
number four yeah so be quiet
so be sure be sure that the minute you
set that foot on my property
okay i'll end it okay no problem listen
listen to me
listen listen listen listen listen
listen number one i'm not jihadi
number one number two your family if
anybody touch your family i will kill
them myself first so don't give me that
crap
don't give me that crap yeah don't give
me that crap of
jihadi i'm gonna come listen your family
tommy tommy i've listened to you listen
to me your family is like my family
if anyone comes to my family i will kill
them and if anyone comes near your
family i'll kill them you wouldn't you
know what you would do
you would only you only care about what
none what muslims do but when they say
non-muslim do they think you don't care
look cut the rubbish cut the nonsense
i'm not going to come to your house with
one condition with me
just be quiet tommy be quiet i don't
care i know you're working with me
yeah there's a lot what about it do you
know any muslims
yes i know a few yes why what about it
i'm not gonna speak to him
about me what's gonna change i know look
i know you selling heroin
i know your stash got stolen in one of
your house i know your wife owned a
um look i know all this nonsense man you
i know you say so heroin
i know that [ __ ] what's the
possibility
look look look i've got stuff if i show
it you will crack your pants so
cut the rubber back yeah okay tommy are
you going to meet me or not
listen listen i'm telling you the boxing
match will happen
why are you keep on be such a [ __ ]
coward
do you think i am scared of throwing
punches
uh no okay right you can pick them up
okay i'll prove you wrong on the day i'm
telling you
we're gonna we're gonna have a debate
after the debate we're gonna go
no no
you want to raise your profile no i
don't know tommy i've got a bigger
following than you
what are you talking about you've got
you're not talking about tommy
i'm not why are we you acting like i'm a
number like i'm this guy who's got 500
subscribers on youtube
tommy you are okay chat nonsense tommy
i'm telling you if you do not meet me
i'm gonna find you i'm gonna track you
down i know where you live what i have
to do is
way outside your house follow you uh
down the road and just
boom got five cameras on you i'm telling
you look i don't wanna embarrass you
meet me like a man i swear to god i
don't want to embarrass me i control you
okay listen man to man listen to me
man's man man
i'm challenging you as a kaffar as a mom
i'm challenging you i've challenged you
to a
wow okay you know what you know what
tommy you know what tell me tell me you
know i feel sorry
you've got no choice but to write it
you've got no choice but to rise to it
but you're that much of a [ __ ] yellow
belly [ __ ] coward
you won't even [ __ ] do it what's a
yellow belly
i've heard you yeah yellow belly smelly
jelly whoever yeah i don't know you just
said yeah
okay what you're doing is this tommy
here you know
that you're gonna get destroyed
intellectually and you know
you know what you know what either
you're thinking three minutes
at least have some respect have some
dignity now you know
intel [ __ ] she's moving cheers yeah i
know a bit yeah i have a bit of
everything
now that's why now you're thinking okay
how could i get out of this
um i know i know once again i know
i don't know so much yeah in four
minutes
if you can finish me in five minutes
then why don't you meet me if you look
if i'm so easy look there was an imam
you met an imam
about it okay let me
let's meet and debate live okay yeah
on the same night as that let's box okay
i'm gonna give you one more last chance
are you going to debate me or not yeah
okay i'm going to where we're going to
debate
it buff don't be such a little [ __ ]
right
you're a man you better be a man tell me
you know your words already be
you know your words are just like you
follow me ad hominins don't mean nothing
to me
listen listen listen you're crapping
yourself i don't know
i don't want to get bang out of it i
want to get something out of it no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
no
you know you want to do that you know
what you want to get out of it you just
want to run away that's what you're
gonna and i'm not gonna give you that
mate
you are not gonna get that i'm gonna
destroy you you know you know your book
you know your book ali what do you do
you know you know what i couldn't i
don't listen to me this is me
i've already got tape recordings of you
okay yeah
you have no idea i've already got what i
need to do
okay one video okay no problem listen
yes be a man
you better be a muslim yeah be a man
you're gonna be superior to me
all you do is look at your words you've
got such a filthy mouth what is wrong
with you man
because your
look oh my gosh what's my family got to
do with anything man
you're such a coward
you bring my parents you bring
measures and that's what you're doing i
understand you're disappointed are you
going to be
out are you going to meet me or not yes
okay where and when
me debate box okay where and when are we
going to debate
and box where are we going to look
listen you know when boxes what these
boxes do they have
listen listen what does boxers do listen
listen
boxers they have a weigh-in you know
when you weigh in and they come to each
other and say blah blah blah
and then they then they arrange a boxing
day i'm saying to you let's have that
first and the boxing match will come
forget be
stopping you run your mouth everybody
but when it's alienware you're all
silent and you're all shaky
oh so let's meet up let's have the
debate let's have the way in
and have the date set for when we're
going to go let's have the debate
everything else will follow
i can't believe you know you know if you
ran me out with any muslim if any
muslims
they said listen man to man do you know
what i did once with him in nine years
one muslim in nine years
has come to me hand to hand one man yeah
and i shook his hand afterwards
okay shook his hand afterwards okay
thank you so much to you
okay yeah yeah i i i i'm scared to
debate
yeah exactly
like muhammad said you're a wimp my
friend said wimp because he's scared of
a little fat white kid
he's scared of the little fat one tommy
you're just a funny guy
don't worry i'm scared i'm a very scared
person i'm just you know i'm just
kidding i'm not i'm scared i'm scared
i'm scared no problem am i going to meet
are you going to meet me or am i going
to find you which one is it going to be
do you think you're going to vomit stop
acting look you're acting like a jihadi
yeah do you have you you're so violent
guy
you're so violent i'm gonna say this
appears morgan you know what i'm gonna
say look at this guy look how violent he
is
i'm saying to you are you gonna meet me
am i gonna find you i want a charitable
a charitable am i gonna
are you going to meet me i'm going to
find you i'll find you
okay you find me yeah that's even better
look look
you find me in the comments what are you
doing
that's a nice one to me and what's gonna
happen after i gave him a date and time
he didn't come look you can try anything
tell me i'm gonna catch you
on it's gonna be so embarrassing tommy
save yourself an embarrassment i'm
actually i'm feeling sorry for you
do you know what's gonna happen when i
pop at you with three cameras one live
do you know how embarrassing that's
gonna be
ally your own family don't talk to you
what's that boy do with anything oh my
god okay
okay okay my family got to talk about me
okay my friend one mom and dad
yes you will have one [ __ ] every
person has one mom and dad yes the most
important people see them in their life
yes
and they don't talk to you okay firstly
let's suppose they don't talk to me okay
and your point is you're a [ __ ] joker
box oh my god
your family don't talk to you and so
what you're a joker bro you sound like a
four-year-old kid
are you going to look i've got this you
have no morals
your own family your mum and dad bro
very scum
and you don't even speak to your family
okay all right tommy all right [ __ ]
joker running around wait
where the media makes you happy tommy
okay when are we when are we meeting
i'm gonna make a video tomorrow
i know you're there i know which hotel
you're right look it's not hard to find
me i say where i am
no you don't no you don't no you don't
recently you've been a bit careful
no you don't stop chatting nonsense
ali yes that's okay okay
i'm going to give you another minute
you have the opportunity to silence me
in every way
look you've written my life you said
that if i claim to though you're going
to kill me
i can easily go look look i can easily
go to the police with that and say look
i'm going to go to this guy house
so
if you don't come to me i will find you
i'm gonna find you
okay
i don't i don't care i don't care do
what you're like look you're then you're
the jihadi i'm not the jihadi
you are a jihadist i've got a
one freakish one second your kids and
what has your kids got to do with me
i'm coming to you why are you being
dramatic you come to my house with my
children in my family oh my gosh
okay okay okay i come to your house and
i ring you and go tommy i'm outside your
house you want to come out for a debate
you're going to call me
you'll end me okay you come and do that
i will do
okay you do that hand on heart no
problem do it do it do it
people people will see people see who
the jihadist
they go the guys
tommy please man you sound pathetic you
sound like a child
you sound like a child tommy are you do
you do you say like are you really
emotional
like you seem like a very emotional guy
all i'm asking is for a discussion man
you go after all these muslims
look at jada and paul they were doing
the same thing i confronted them
in their own march i went to the police
station they started crying and ran
through the back door
annie i'll tell you the truth do you
know you know i said to you just because
of how much you've wanted it
the final reason why no no no no no no
because you know you've got the pressure
stop chatting not so you know you've got
the pressure the pressure is on you
you know your own followers are like
tell me why are you not defeating him
tell me what's going on tell me
tell me yeah exactly that silence is
enough for you
that silence there is enough for you
tommy well that's silence i think that
is
that's it that's the sound of your
mother it's a moment of silence for you
because you know why because you're i'm
going to destroy your friend's body
how do you know i don't talk to them
what the hell has that got to do with
this
how do you how do you know how to talk
to my mom and dad how do you know you
should make the repairs with your mom
oh my gosh what do you think i can't
believe tommy robinson is telling me
about my family she's going to be i'm
listening to you guys
where else do you advise me tommy go on
that's what i advise you
tommy allah says in the quran when your
parents reach old age don't even say off
to them you don't know my relationship
with my mom and dad
and even the quran exactly there you go
i live with my mom and dad they live
upstairs man i see them every day you
clown just shut up
stop being a [ __ ] just you're just an
idiot seriously
i'm i'm not muslim are you no they're
not
they're not no they're not i'm a revert
my mom and dad is not
well my mom kind of took a shahada you
know this is quite funny actually look
at me and you're talking about this
so you wasn't born in alloway no i my
family's my mom's side is alloy i
had no religion okay see see your mom
you was born
look look my dad's phone my dad yeah is
he's suppo he's kurdish yeah okay you
guys are okay with it
i'll tell you what that is i'll tell you
what that is yeah a good guy okay
okay who doesn't accept he has okay and
and you've gone
full the other way now
what's that what's the sick that i've
joined gone what were you talking about
what sect
your own family your own family know
full well
yeah you have solved them out rough you
had
you you had an opportunity i've had this
you have an opportunity to have your own
identity
and you've got identities
i am kurdish as well and your point is
that should be your identity
i'm a muslim
okay okay one second one second one
second i know that i know that
but what's that god do with islam what's
that god do with islam
what do you mean what he could do what
has caused me but if you've sold your
own [ __ ]
you you have right now you're from under
the most [ __ ]
identifiably the best [ __ ] most proud
set and you [ __ ] sold them out what
are you
tommy what are you talking about me
seriously i'm genuinely trying to
understand inside
do have you heard of the term before ha
have you heard of it
yeah what who are they
love what do you say who are you
what are you going to try what are you
going to try when you're going to try
and
you don't even know the prophet said
anyone who finds this
kill them who's he talking about these
isis these isis who want to kill us
oh shut your trap isis want to kill me
you're a maniac oh at least at least i
have respect for them you know leave
this killer
at least i have respect for it why'd his
wife
what's that why did you have this would
you have respect for leaving this killer
are you flipping mad
he's not coward he's not [ __ ] like you
he's my god
you are you respected
he's following the commandments he's
following the instructions
to the word okay he's following him
through words
he gets 55 verses 55 verses
okay i dare you let's go for all of them
i dare you me me 55 verses will go
through all of them
i challenge you man i'm gonna destroy
you you are mad
you are fantastic
ask me what if you never chat let me ask
you something why have you never
challenged
adjunct because he's locked up
before he was locked up no no before
he's locked up when i never saw him i
never came across him why have you never
chat okay
because why have you never challenged
play to live on who the hell is he for
islam i don't know who he is all i know
is
that's the only one guy i know
listen mate listen
should i tell you something if you look
if you want let me tell you something if
you want to be
a real man we will go after both
extremists whoever they are
muslim are non-muslim grooming gangs
there you go you're sick you know when
we had our first demonstration in
louisiana when we were on our first
demonstration i don't know we come
across
and i sat and i sat down in the past
yeah yeah and then there's a white keys
there and there's 200 people from living
there
and this lad went from looming so i sat
down next to him i said wait oh well
where you from he said barney
he goes don't worry bob dirty national
phone just got off the train station
yeah
i said listen brother you see when they
get here we're going to smash their
[ __ ] heads in
okay and he looked at me like what i
said we're going to smash their [ __ ]
engine bruh
look around this pub and then i remember
we 10 of us broke away from the police
where the national front were and we
[ __ ] licked them up took all their
[ __ ] off and threw it and i remember
watching all the muslim taxi drivers
stand there clapping
and then i went over some muslim tax
drivers and said don't [ __ ] cap
that's what we do to our extremists
that's what we will do to them you see
if i see the national fan house on my
house or perhaps they're [ __ ] it
yeah the difference is you haven't done
that to them okay that's the difference
okay one second you have not done one
second then why did i get live threats
for me because i did a video saying that
if i knew an extremist muslim i would
call the police
why was i why was i getting death
threats from isis members
who live in the uk telling me you are
going to grasp us up and i was like are
you dumb
our scholars have said that we it's upon
us to call
the police on those who are extremes who
want to kill the innocent people
you are listening that's great ali
that's great yeah the 66 percent of
british muslims wouldn't wouldn't
no that's not absolutely where did you
get the statistics from where did you
get the statistics from
that [ __ ] that segment
the biggest the biggest uh statistics
that was done was by gallup if i'm not
missing
and they went to 30 countries and
interviewed 50 000 muslims and 93
percent of them said
they are against jihadi attacks and
they're seven percent i'm not finished
let me finish
seven percent who said that they're not
is for political reasons
let me tell you why bush and tony blair
these two people who said they saw
christ
i've listened to you i'm listening to
you let me finish let me finish yeah
i've listened to you let me finish here
these two people let me tell you what's
causing extremism tony blair and bush
they went to iraq for oil
bombed millions of innocent men women
and children
let me finish let me finish i've
listened to this in your back
if they didn't come into my country
thank you
so what do these emotional immature
muslims do
they get on an emotional wave and say
look they've done that to our provinces
we're going to do the same back
does the quran teach that no the quran
says our enemies are not our teachers
just because they come and kill men
women and children we don't do the same
okay okay so if you if you there's a
video on youtube in losing yeah
and it's it's a gaza war protest and
when when we first started the edl i
went to a meeting in lumbar council
with all with a baroness with about
eight people from the council and there
was a muslim kid there
and i sat down and there was all
represented to the council
and i said where do you live so all the
people from our representatives yeah
where do you live
none of them lived in louisiana none of
them were working class or middle class
you where do you live where you were
and i looked at her saying the muslim
visa okay i said you live in very park
you said yeah you actually are in touch
with your community
so this is the problem you know and then
he said and then what he said to me
he said he said that satan is loving
that group we're against them
you know so i got a laptop out and i
showed him an anti-gaza war protest
where thousands of blues marched through
lewin
and they were led by safe and islam
let's reverse it save islam are the
equivalent of neo-nazis with dr martin's
and bomber jackets on there
and what i said to him is that the
problem is i'll show you this
and you all followed them yeah and
they're showing kaiba kyogre i said now
the difference is
you see if that was a national fun we
would kick their [ __ ] heads in
you know nazis are walking through our
town yeah i said but now the difference
is
that's the difference now when the
muslims come out against faithful islam
and that group in louisiana you can
watch the video over here
i sent kadir basque that was when we
first started the upl
i sent kadir back an email and i said do
you know what you've done today
because all the muslims confronted the
extremists i said what you've done today
was
was good that's what we need but the
reasons you've done it
were wrong yeah because you've done it
because your mosque got blown up
you've done it because 500 people
running around balaclavas
you didn't do it for the last 10 years
you didn't do it for the great good of
our community
you didn't do it to stop them promoting
hatred against us
you didn't you stood there for the last
[ __ ] 10-15 years
and you don't [ __ ] off okay don't [ __ ]
off can i say something
yeah i don't know i don't know who this
facebook stamp is i don't know who
you're talking about by the way yeah
unless supporters
okay by the way i totally disagree with
that what what he did there i find it
very disgusting yeah okay
you know what you know what i told me
because you want you love people doing
that because it supports your agenda
because you're going to
understand that you know what and you
know tommy i'm not going to do that
you don't tell me i'm not going to right
now you know i'm not going to do that
no no i respect him in the sense that
once he's done that
i drove around and as i come around i
see him on his phone and he's lost his
head off
where he's mainly just ringing up his
mate saying i just [ __ ] punched tommy
robinson
now the point is so he said i've got him
back i've gone back anyway yeah okay
look that's not that's not my friend
look my issue with you is this yeah look
i i am activist i am after grooming
gangs be it
white or non-white extremists be white
or non-white
you have a sick man you only go after
muslims just muslims
i'm telling you i'm telling you i am
ready look let me tell you something if
you really are what you say
why don't you join me then we will go
after both
grooming gangs that are muslim and
non-muslim extremists
then then i will say to you then i will
say you know what you're a man but you
know what you do you insult our religion
i'm a prophet and you chat live you lied
so i want to meet you
and let's go through if i would if we
are taught to kill the kuffar
i want to go through that after that
then me and you we can hold hands and
jump along no problem
but firstly we need to establish that
because you have been lying
and nowhere in the quran does it say go
and discriminately kill the kuffar why
because they could
rubbish rubbish go and tell me go away
all right you're your version of
innocent version of innocent this is
where we differ
oh is it okay all right all right go to
quran says in the quran allah does not
forbid you from being just and kind
to those who do not fight you in your
faith and kick you out your houses what
does that mean
and when that's it what what what what
year was that
and by the way one other thing that's
funny is your book about chronological
order
tommy i don't know your friend did a
really bad job that was that's not
abrogated
this verse here chapter 60 verse eight i
dare you to go to it you will see it
very clearly it says
allah look i'll read it for you allah
does not forbid you
from being just and kind to those who do
not fight you
on account of your faith yeah okay what
this look look at this next verse
allah forbids you only about those who
fought
you on account of your faith and
expelled you from your homes and helped
others in explaining you
that you have friendship with them what
does that mean the prophet was
persecuted for
flipping 12 years his companions were
killed you're telling me if i come to
your house you will kill me
and the prophet he got kicked out of his
house he got killed
and after so many years in quran chapter
22
39 that's when allah said the permission
to fight and defend yourself has been
given
and you know you've been nonsense so be
a man and say you know what i've been
chatting rubbish then i won't debate you
but
you don't what are we doing the wrong
tree because you know the people you
need to be screaming
is all those jihadi little [ __ ]
and how do you know i don't know don't
don't you don't [ __ ] when i've always
excuse me you give me you give me the
addresses
give me addresses of these guys i can't
find them for some reason i don't know
what what you use
how do you know how all right tell me
how do you know them i don't know how to
find them
do you think i have a genie bottle like
oh where's where
is it no no no okay what is in house
arrest where is the conservation
there was no terrorist attack in iraq
there was no terrorist attack in iraq
until the invasion happening in 2004 was
the first suicide attack here
what did what when when one day i
suppose
no no no i do i do because you're making
it seem you're making it seem like we're
muslims
hit me up can i ask me can i speak here
don't be like jada
don't be like jada she was a lady i gave
her the benefit of doubt yeah okay let
me speak here
look george bush they asked him did you
ask your father when you went to iraq he
said of course i did i asked my heavenly
father
this guy is a christian he is a
christian when you have these
christian priests who are raping little
boys yeah raping little boys do we go
and say
that's that's church and these people
are they know the religion they're
bloody priests
these morons who go and run people over
these morals who go
wrong people over these these flipping
scumbags
who run innocent men women and children
this is what hurts me
you know what you know what hurts me let
me tell you something let me tell you
you know what hurts me
the fact that you know you you you
preach hate
as much as these isis scumbags and you
know what happens let me finish let me
finish let me finish what happens
you know what hurts me you know what
it's look look i'm not going to call you
racist because i know
you're not racist yeah and i know you
always want to say oh when was that
racist okay
so you preach hey you say look at this
muslim this muslim that muslim this
muslim
why do you not bring christianity into
it why don't you talk about buddhism why
do they talk about israel killing
thousands of people why don't you talk
about that
listen right if you if you look if you
come to luke and know any other person's
illusion
you'll know that i have had no problems
with muslims in fact i used to chill
with all of them
i used to know all of their phones i
used to hang around my best mate was in
manasma and then man and cameron they're
my best friends yeah
when i was growing up so i don't hate
muslims even when i said to them
i said listen i i have a problem with
the ideology you follow that doesn't
mean i hate you
no no no no no no no tommy tommy you've
been a hypocrite you know why do you
know you posted something
you posted something of a white lady
being searched with a metal detector
by a somalian girl in a hijab and he
said look at the irony
yeah and what were you trying to
insinuate there so are you so
no no no no why did you post that
let me tell you what i was insinuating
when you go through an airport like we
do
and you get stopped and searched all of
that the whole
[ __ ] system is because of islam the
whole [ __ ] thing
is because jihadi [ __ ] want to
blow us up the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
so it wasn't because she's wearing a
hijab
and she's been stopped searched and
[ __ ] handled by a [ __ ] muslim
woman
it's [ __ ] by okay what's wrong with
what's wrong with a muslim woman who's a
british doing her job
keeping their country secure well what
comes first
is it islam or is it proof look look to
us to us muslims
islam comes first to us i'm not going to
come and sugarcoat you
islam but that does not mean that
doesn't mean
that i'm gonna violate the laws no i
have a passport that possible means i
obey the law of the land
meaning i obey if a police officer i'm
you you attack the police officer
i'm not i'm not gonna go and flip an
attack a police officer
you have a criminal record i try my with
my best to stay away and not get in
trouble why
because i have to obey the law of the
land i grew up in lincoln i don't i i
grew up in tottenham i grew up in
tottenham and
real life yeah so so so you
look i'm telling you look i i need to
pick up my wife now here
i'm just telling you look i look i've
got no problem with your family
i told you this before you posted
something about merry christmas i said
hopefully
look let me finish let me finish this
let me finish man let me finish
tommy let me finish here i'm telling you
something here okay
i'm not let me tell you something i'm
not going to come to your house not
because i'm scared of you
look if you come next to me yeah i'm not
i'm not
look look no no you can't look if you
come try anything with me yeah
look i'm not an idiot i'm just going to
stand there hi tommy yeah okay
i'm coming to debate you yeah i'm going
to come and debate you on this topic on
this matter that's what i want to come
for here
after that boxing match kickboxing match
thai boxing super boxing flying boxing
no problem but i'm telling you you have
been lying
your book is full of lies with your
friends book which you have your name on
it
these are full of lies you either
retract them or
you debate me like a man will go through
anything you want in islam no problem
anything apostasy this that no problem
no problem
but i'm saying to you this your family
when you posted something on christmas
i tweeted and said god bless your family
i'm not that type mate i'm not the type
to have a problem with you
or your family in that context all i'm
saying is you've been lying you've been
telling a little poor keys either take
those porkies back and eat them
or tell the truth about it that's what i
want so when are we going to debate
because i need to go when are we going
to debate
what i'll do is tomorrow i'll make a
video give you a time
and a place to the right okay on the box
like i said to you before you do what
you want i'm going to debate you that's
a coward what is wrong with you
no no no no no no look i'm a coward i'm
telling you
look i am a coward i'm a coward okay
when are we debating why you want to
raise money
no no no no i don't want to raise money
well go on i'm a coward okay when are we
debating
i'm a coward look i'm telling you i am a
coward okay no problem
yes i'm okay i'm scared you know your
left hook will really scare me okay
when are we gonna have a debate
i'll give you a video as well okay there
you go so we'll let people know
you're the coward we'll let people know
who the coward is okay so i'm telling
you don't get mad at me when i come and
find you don't come and say ali you know
look i'm telling you don't be mad i've
given you opportunity over and over
again
give me a time and place i'll come and
debate you like you you catch that imam
guy on the flipping bench
and he was talking to him i'm here
flipping dying i'm literally begging you
and you're like oh boxing match this
match that match
because where's the game where's the
game for me what what
do i get you know what you you know what
you get by with me
i could meet [ __ ] like you every
day of the week
you've got insults yeah there we go look
let me tell you something i'm i'm i'm
i'm a different i'm a different kind i'm
quite unique let me tell you why yeah
cause let me tell you yeah
because when you meet me the british
public is gonna know i'm an orthodox
museum and i follow the quran and the
sunnah and i don't sugarcoat my religion
and i love the land that i live in and i
obey the land and i'm against these
bloody isis scumbags who want to kill me
my life is flipping in danger as much as
it's yours and that
we care about the british government i
mean the british public
as much as i do and we don't want
innocent people dying i mean if you if
you're really against those things
interesting yes then let's meet up when
i meet up with you
okay are you against the way of course
sorry are you against me
that god do with foreign i'm asking you
a simple question are you
because there's so many things that as a
muslim that i think the muslims should
be doing
no we're talking about look look look
look we believe in the sharia look look
we i'm telling you i'm not sure
we believe in the sharia but the sharia
is not the sherry that you think in your
head
kill stone look sharia is a whole system
you know child benefit
that's the sharia housing keeping the
homeless getting them a house
that's sharia so you have the different
ideas
so you support
excuse me hold on a second do you know
the orthodox jews they have their own
laws
do you have a problem with that yeah
okay come with me to stamford hill where
i live nearby and let's go to them we'll
go
we'll go to them and let me see your
problem you get you get paid by the
zionists
don't chat nonsense tommy tommy you i
know you get funded by yeah you will
never go to the jews and do this
yes you don't stop chatting nonsense
tommy
please tell me i don't make a penny on
youtube you know that i don't make a
penny of what i do
i don't make a penny yeah no yes you do
yes you do yes you do look yeah
look look look look listen why don't you
go to the jewish community they have the
haredi sect yeah in the
in stamford deal they're girls and boys
are separate in schools they believe in
the old testament
the apostasy a person who apostates they
should be killed a woman who
commits adultery stoned to death uh if
you worship any others
have you seen it do you see them kill
anyone yes in israel that guy who went
on the gay parade and stabbed a few gay
people
in israel in israel in israel tell me
one thing
why does it have to be in the uk are you
like is it like is you can't empty
around the world
okay so that's another thing i wanted to
say you have a personal problem with
muslims
it's not islam you you was you was
dealing you was dealing with drug
dealers yeah you know one thing i always
wonder
you have a personal problem with muslims
because i know your cousin reverted to
islam
yeah and i know some other personal
stuff i don't want to get into here but
you have a personal problem with muslims
asians and you're taking it out on islam
that's exactly what's happening
100 billion
[ __ ] that's your problem you know
you know that tommy tommy you know that
you have a problem because and let me
tell you something whatever these
muslims did
to you and how i did it i apologize on
their behalf for how they made you feel
that that that that you feel like this
sounds like
you're all the main gangs you know if i
see them they shake my hand
every single one of them shake my hand
look at that
no no no
tomorrow i'm looking for your date and
time where i'm going to meet you
that's all i'm looking forward to yeah
so i'm going to pick up i need to pick
up my family now
okay and i'm gonna go so all i'm gonna
say to you is
look i want to speak like a man to man
yeah we're gonna have a debate we're
gonna have a discussion not even a
debate let's have a discussion let's
talk let's sit down
say say timmy tell me your concern say
ali these are my concerts i have these
concerts one two three
at the same time and at the same time
let's
base money for jerry don't worry about
that we're going to come to that look
look
look i don't understand i'm a coward
okay look
i'm telling you i look look i am a
coward
i accept no problem nope okay i accept
it
okay a date and time for the uh debate
so i don't have to end up finding you
it's gonna you know take me a bit of a
time here cause i have to track you down
exactly
and you know you're like a bit of you
all over the place sometimes you [ __ ]
know jack you know
you're not gonna know you've been
tracking me down you haven't been
anywhere leaving tommy tommy [ __ ] you
know not that hard to find i mean i walk
around town every day
tell me i know anyone can follow me tell
me i know when to find out
so you're actually not [ __ ]
i know you've been a bit careful to
where you say you are and when you are i
know i've noticed that
and you're used to that you used to say
openly somebody i'm going to be in
manchester but recently i've seen you a
bit
you go and say on the day hey i'm in
this place now
um tommy yes yes
yes tommy anyways if i wanted to find
you if i had a point with you
please find me at least make my life
easy look you come to me
i don't want to find you you're [ __ ]
like me i don't want to find
yeah yeah there's nobody that you follow
and call yeah
tell me you know you're crapping it yeah
no tommy don't give me a man i know i
know you even know
even for your voice i know you you you
go you know you're you're shook you know
you're in big trouble
oh my god do you believe in oh yeah by
the way do you believe in god
no i don't know oh you don't so i
thought he was a jew it was a cause if
there was
yeah he wasn't wearing [ __ ] sandals
and a dress well that you know that's
close to islam we don't believe that we
don't believe god is a man by the way
that's
[Music]
you stopped drinking alcohol as well
you're getting close to islam you know
that
i but i thought i heard you as a jew is
it true
i heard that you said you're jewish or
something like that
no i'm just asking i'm not i'm not i
swear to god i heard someone
oh okay so you don't you have no
religion yeah
no i didn't say i have no religion i
don't believe in the church all right
are you a christian would you class
yourself as a christian no i'm a
christian
okay so if i say to you for example just
to finish off in the book of samuel
chapter 15 verse 23 where god
orders amalek has to go kill men women
children babies and donkeys
do you know this is ordered by god
almighty in your book
can you find me anything similar in the
quran in the hadith anywhere
well well in the answers you know is
that the instructions of god
yes it's instruction by god it says go
to the americas
this is the book this is the book of
samuel chapter 15 verse 23 it says go to
the malaca this is everything
sent by god to use but god or god's word
who else can it be
it says go to amelica kill men women
children baby and donkey yeah i'm asking
you show me a
similar verse in the quran of the hadith
anyway don't mean the last time you saw
a christian killing a man woman baby a
donkey
oh oh yeah sure definitely um for
example bush who said i spoke to my
heavenly father and blew up one million
muslims
uh kkk uh african in african central
africa
the militants in africa who are chopping
uh and eating muslims burning them
and there's also man are you crusaders
crusaders you know she took over
palestine
um you know what he did did he kill
they didn't what did the christian army
the the leaders say
he said we killed your men women and
children why are you not doing the same
he said i
am not like those men and that is the
real islam tommy
that is the real listener you don't need
to stress that to me you need to stress
that to the [ __ ]
no because you've been lying you've been
lying you've been lying anyway listen i
need to go
good night it was nice talking to you i
want to have a nice discussion with you
please give me a date and time tomorrow
on your video i'm looking forward to it
and thanks for giving me your number and
like i said to you before
let's talk and let's deal with the issue
and you need to retract your statement
or i will retract it for you
oh my god [ __ ] hell you believe
you're in hotel
a bit yeah [ __ ] you know
have a nice time at drewsburg what's
that
i said have a nice time at drewsbury um
why don't you go up to the blitz mosque
in jerusalem
why do i need to confront some [ __ ]
listen listen listen
listen listen let me let me first deal
with you after that i've got a long list
of a lot of people that i'm going to go
after
and a lot of them don't worry don't
worry just wrong
and by the way help me help me and find
give me about his address by the way
give give me that what are we gonna do
do you leave that to me leave that to me
leave that to me you leave that to me
so how easy it is this is the difference
yeah this is different when i walk
through
my young muslims come up to me with all
their tunes
you drink in the it's the milk you drink
beer in the biscuit meal
yeah here you are trying to [ __ ] up to
me about some religious [ __ ]
you [ __ ] drink all the
exactly time you so these muslims look
let me tell you something
jayda said to me shake my hand yeah if i
cannot even shake a woman's hand where
do you think it tells us to go and groom
young innocent girls yeah let's listen
so when i
is the most extreme muslim
in the uk yeah i don't know when he
walks okay when he walks through the
muslim community
he gets no this is what the egl was
about what we thought it was about
was to try and put pressure on them to
deal with the decades in their own
community
which we thought it would work they
didn't we thought they'd turn on them
but they didn't okay
so these little [ __ ] stand outside
set up their stalls every [ __ ] week
in our in in the muslim community
and now if i open my curtains tomorrow
and i see the national front with a
stall nurse on my window
i'm gonna go out there and keep [ __ ] up
tommy listen listen listen
the difference is that's how we deal
with our [ __ ] extremists
the problem is the muslim trading with
all these albums revealing with random
childhood all that group in london
they've done [ __ ] all for 20 years
what's your name
both of them are the two sides of one
coin which is extremism
both of them and both of them are
creating conflict
and this tiny group are hijacking the
religion and the other ones are
attacking the religion and both of them
are ignorant
because they don't know that muslims not
every muslim is a terrorist
the other ones and these guys they have
no knowledge of religion
and they are tainting the image of islam
okay
okay okay all right let's suppose for
argument's sake muslims are not doing
nothing
i'm telling you from now on it's going
to change
yeah okay that's it so i need to go pick
up my wife before she kicks my head in
okay i'll see you tomorrow at your video
take care